j'ai rêvé de ça toute ma
vie
et l'or du géant c'est le plus gros
trésor qui n'a jamais été trouvé cinq
milliards facile
alors quand est-ce qu'on commence ouais mets ça dans
ta tête
bonjour bonjour
je peux l'entendre assis juste à côté
ton frère croyait ça  il y a eu un
dernier morceau
attends tu sais mon frère Sam, quoi d'autre
tu ne me dis pas que
tu n'as aucune idée de qui tu es en partenariat, ça
prend un peu plus de temps que je ne le
pensais les enfants, je
suppose que nous sommes 50 50, c'est vrai
50 50. tu en as 10  pour cent c'est moi qui
suis généreux wow
jouons aux parachutes
à moins que tu saches une meilleure façon de sauter dessus
oh mon dieu je suis vraiment désolé
allez il y a
500 ans ma famille a trouvé le
vautour et a été trahie
tellement de sang
tu te débrouilles très bien
ça  ce n'est pas fini
hé tu es toujours avec moi à peine qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec le chat elle est juste réelle quelle
vie semble super triste je ne vais pas garder
ce truc
toi